welcome to google developers weekly
store November eighteenth 2013 I'm Louis
gray and this is our highlight reel of
what's happening in the world of Google
developers on the set and off I often
say that Google is the biggest startup
I've ever worked for but if your startup
is smaller than ours you might be
considering working with an accelerator
like 500 startups or rocket space
trading equity for benefits like office
space and business strategy is it worth
it Don dodge shares his experience with
us and provides advice also many
startups these days selling premium
services find themselves caught between
free open-source software and large
software packages from bigger
competitors offering support and
consulting how can you survive Jay
Simon's president of it lassie and joins
Don to talk about how they navigate this
challenge from New York youtubes eek
I'll and shows us how to manually create
Google credential instances with refresh
tokens as well as access tokens if
you've been looking for tips and tricks
on how to use OAuth with the Java API
this is the show for you a native
applications that run in chrome are a
big part of the web's of platform
portable Native Client or as we call it
pinochle enables secure and portable
execution of these native apps when you
produce a platform-independent form of
your native app chrome translates it to
run on users portable devices at greater
than eighty percent of native
performance very cool stuff check out
the video with moderator Colt McAnlis
and some of Google's product leads on
Native Client to learn more France s
campoy and kurt's we're teamed up to
show us how they leverage Google's cloud
and go language to visualize big data
building an app that maps shipping using
the google maps api we brought you
clouds to Google Earth and now you can
see what maps can do with cloud staying
in a google map state of mind GDL hosted
ET val gandhi author of the new Google
Maps engine QGIS connector about how
this plug-in fits into a typical
workflow and where you can get the
source code we also welcome back pong
Jia and Maru as they dive into wallet
objects concepts showing us how well it
objects represented and rendered in the
Google Wallet app i tend to know what
few objects are in my physical wallet
and now i'll know what objects are my
google wallet to cloud platform maven
paul rashidi then joins us for a quick
walk through of the google compute
engine API on Android demoing a sample
app that connects the Google compute
engine API and all week we've been happy
to host
new courses from the google developers
heck Adam II this week focused on the
Android SDK presented by Enrique Diaz
from the GDG Android tip not told us las
clases Sonnen espanol stepping outside
the studio we have more updates from the
world of google developers on thursday
we celebrate an important milestone is
dark turned 10 dart is a modern language
for building structured web apps and now
it's officially ready for your
production apps find out all the cool
details at dartlang.org and get started
you already know that you can use a
Google Drive SDK to build apps that are
highly integrated with drive and now
there's a powerful new way to integrate
with Gmail use the new SDK features to
make drive enabled apps that let users
open docs in your app without ever
leaving gmail and to make sure that you
never miss a thing from the world of
google developers subscribe to google
developers on youtube and check out the
gdl schedule at
developers.google.com/live I'm Louis
gray and I'll see you in the studio